hey everybody it's the love doctor here
your romance Guru from the daily wire to
help those of you who are struggling in
your romantic life to go out there and
get the guy or girl of your dreams now
I'm I'm gonna Focus here mostly on the
fellas trying to get the ladies the
reason I got to make this video is
because there are a lot of people who
are giving advice to young men who are
having an increasingly difficult time
and their romantic lives and they're
giving them kind of bad advice clap slap
grab choke shut up sex okay and so I as
a board-certified love physician have to
come in and correct the record this
video is sponsored by gen yosel or from
them in a minute first let's get started
I saw a video by someone named the wheat
worker or something what's the guy's
name wheat waffle and the wheat waffle
had advice for men this is the tried and
true rationalist system for how to get a
chick Okay so so here's what he had to
say in this video I'm going to be
telling you how you should play your
cards in dating based on your looks in
other words depending on which category
you fall you'll have a different set of
procedures to get the best bang for your
buck out of dating any blue box is an
action you need to take for example
looks maxing and any green box is a
question you need to ask yourself the
first of which is are you a sub 5 Normie
or Chad's okay all right so
he's saying I'm basing all of this on
looks
I'm not saying looks don't matter looks
matter a lot
but looks actually are not the most
important thing even if you want to
improve how you look you shouldn't think
first of how you look you've got to look
at something a little deeper so he opens
up with are you sub five a kind of one
to ten scale I assume
are you ignore me or are you a Chad so
I've changed this
to are you homely are you a normie
you're basically an average to perfectly
fine looking person or are you a big you
know Giga Chad Adonis
so which of those do you fall into and
then this guy he says okay if you're a
sub five can you looks Max to Normie and
I take by looks Max he means can you hit
the gym get certain even maybe get
cosmetic procedures done can you get
better clothing can you do whatever you
got to do grow a beer or something to to
bump yourself up from the homely
category to the normal category okay and
then for the Chad he doesn't need to
worry about the looks Max okay I get rid
of that get out of here get out of here
man
now the question you have to ask
yourself is are you virtuous now if
you're a normie the question you've got
to ask yourself is are you virtuous okay
and then and this is where it gets a
little confusing if you were just a cool
hot Giga Chad
the question that you should ask
yourself
before you start to analyze your dating
life is are you virtuous
so that's going to be a yes or a no if
you are not virtuous you should practice
virtue if you are virtuous we'll get to
that in a second the reason you should
begin with this here is not because I'm
trying to avoid the issue of looks or
the issue of you know dieting or going
to the gym or anything like that but if
you practice the virtues you will look
smacks you will look better because
let's say you've fallen into the sin of
of gluttony that's one of your vices
well if you practice virtue you're going
to stop being quite so gluttonous you're
going to put the cupcake down but it's
not only going to end it's not going to
end there because you're going to have
other things that you think about as
well are you I don't know lustful well
if you're really lustful that's going to
screw up your dating life one you're
probably going to be looking at a bunch
of porn and you know doing what Woody
Allen called having sex with someone you
love and that's not going to make you
look good it's going to make you look
terrible it's going to make you have a
have your brain melt and it's going to
to cause you to be on like a big weirdo
like a pervert you know so you don't
want to do that start out by virtue
maxing that will fix all of these other
problems not just your looks but all the
rest of you because you're an integrated
person you're not just a facade with
like either the chiseled cool Chad jaw
or the you know no Chin kind of homely
not doing very well kind of guy now if
you're practicing the virtues okay then
you go to the next level that's are you
cultured when I say are you cultured I
mean do you know anything about anything
it seems to me that the central part of
the intellectuals have with the free
Society is that it is almost on a
continuing basis area do you have
interests do you have hobbies are you
curious about things do you read books
do you listen to music if you don't if
you're not cultured then the next step
would be learn things learn anything
just pick up any book pick up a book on
Ornithology just anything I promise you
this will be good for you even Beyond
making you more interesting to women it
will make you more interesting to
yourself did you know our friends at gen
yusel have upgraded their most popular
package to feature their top selling
deep firming vitamin C serum plus Ultra
retinol moisturizer with natural retinol
alternative right now you can take
advantage of this limited time package
upgrade for 70 off why waste time and
money to go get work done to your face
when you can get geniusell skin care
shipped right to your door geniusl
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and perfect for both men and women
made by a compounding pharmacist in
small batches and always safe cruelty
free and natural the founder is great
Coptic Christian from Egypt came here
for the American dream go to
geniusell.comyt letter y letter T try
Jenny cell's most popular package for 70
off featuring both genu cells Ultra
retinol and genucel's Firming Serum get
a complimentary spy Essentials box with
every package order plus free upgrade to
priority shipping geniusell.com Knowles
YT that is geniusell.com Knowles y t so
if you are cultured then we move on to
the next phase do you have dating
options within your Social Circle now Mr
wheat waffle also raises this question
so it starts out with the chat here he
says are you looking for a relationship
or casual dating okay so first of all
right there relationship or casual
dating that's another place he's going
totally wrong because he's you're not
going to Virtue max if you're
considering just casually dating that
means just hooking up right rather than
engaging in a love affair with someone
that has an end that is proper and will
be conducive to both of your flourishing
and you're not just consuming one
another for pleasure like you're a
couple of hyenas or demons hopefully
you're interested in love within its
proper context okay good then I say you
say relationship are you interested in
casual dating casual are you
neurotypical neurotypical is one of
these new phrases it just refers to
being Autistic or non-autistic and it's
as if you're if you're autistic then
you've got to go to online dating
because it means you won't be as
socially Adept as other people and if
you're if you're neurotypical then you
should do day and night game and online
dating which is all these little tricks
to pick up chicks and then steal their
virtue and leave them high and dry so
erase all of that okay then though he
says if you're looking for a
relationship do you have dating options
from within your Social Circle if it's a
yes you go to a warm approach if it's no
you go do you live in a big city if the
answer is no it says relocate leave your
nice Community leave your country just
get out of here okay no question is do
you have dating options within your
Social Circle if the answer is yes you
get to the question are you confident
we'll get to that a little bit later if
the answer is no you don't have dating
options within your Social Circle then
you've got to join Social Circles that
include women that you would like to
marry
I know this is mind-blowing stuff here
folks might as well
hey okay maybe instead of looking for
women just in my friends of friends or
you know my sister's friends or
something I'm going to look for women at
a church I'm going to start going to
church if I get involved in politics
I'll join the young Republicans or
something or I'll join a bowling league
I don't know but whatever it is you've
got to put your you're probably not
going to meet a lot of women who want to
get married at a bowling league
but you will at church or other places
like that okay so then you have to put
yourself in those situations it gets
very complicated for this pickup artist
guy here because there are so many
options there's there's no tea loss to
what he's doing there's no point to it
it's just okay is it going to titillate
you to hook up with a blonde today or do
you want to get married and have
children you know there's so many
options here but if you are following
that first step then you're going to
recognize that no everything has a
purpose and dating has a purpose which
is to get married and have children okay
let's say you do have dating options
within your Social Circle question is
are you confident if the answer is no
and we need to go back up the chart to
practice virtue
if you have improved at anything you
will become more confident you'll say I
am able to do something I have some
measure of control over my life don't
try to fake it there are a lot of pickup
artist types will say fake it till you
make it no people smell that out in two
seconds the way to
seem confident
is to be the thing because I'm a
scoundrel that's going to be the best
surest way to get some confidence so are
you confident you've tried that you go
back through the list again okay yes you
are confident so here's the next step
this one this really trips a lot of
people up you need to ask a girl out you
need to go up to a girl and say hey you
want to get a drink sometime hey would
you like to have dinner hey let's go for
a walk if you do that you might get
rejected do you have a six-pack no
foreign
yeah sure you might might get rejected a
bunch but if you do it sincerely not in
a sketchy way you might you might be
accepted even if you're doing a weird
kind of sketchy dodgy way but the better
is to just go up hey you want to go out
oh um
no thank you no one's got a boyfriend
okay all right that's fine it's too bad
lucky guy oh um no I'm not really
interested in a relationship right now
oh okay that's true I sort of am
interested but you know okay that's fine
listen you tell me whenever you're
interested you let me know doesn't need
to be you know are you are you going to
marry me it doesn't need to be how many
children do you want it just be how you
want to get you want to have a cup of
coffee no you got the girl on the date
homely guys Normie guys Chad guys I've
all gotten married for all of human
history you could do it too if you
follow those steps now you got the girl
on the day the question then is do you
find this girl more desirable obviously
you find the girl desirable before the
date that's why you asked her out so
then the question is after that date do
you find her more desirable than you did
before because what that will tell you
is you're not just infatuated you're not
just trying to get a wife get a
girlfriend in a generic way but you
really like this particular person
because you're going to marry a
particular person you're not going to
marry a generic figure the final step is
you ask her out again and then you
repeat this step until you either break
up or get married this is kind of the
real version of you know work on
yourself just work on yourself now don't
just work on yourself and make yourself
feel really good it's do the things that
are objectively are good for you and
will lead to a flourishing life and then
step by step a step by step by step a
step you get married and you have lots
of kids happy dating
[Music]
answers there foreign